it's a thing oh
so much going on on saturdays we walk
pink oh my god see what we did we threw
a mean girls referencing right off the
top just
you did what you needed to do all right
and i'm done that was et canada coming
to you live from wango tango there's
jonathan bennett listen to podcast on i
heart radio see you tomorrow okay you
know what
gemini energy that's what that was
that's that june 10.
june 10th
this is the june 16th
okay
where are you falling in line because i
know that you're newlyweds so what is
the match for me like what sign are you
ares but i think that makes sense right
because like i'm fire get it done and
this one is all over the place never so
i'm just like okay now we're doing this
now we're doing this but we get it all
done because he has 75 things going on
at one time and i just direct him to
finishing the mall huh wait what are we
talking about i like i like that okay
how many times have you seen mean girls
you know what's funny so when jonathan
and i first started dating i hadn't seen
mingle what
i know i know i know
and not because i look sexy with my hair
push back a year in
i love it when you put your hair back
out a few times about a year and my best
friend was like so i think this is real
you probably need to watch the movie and
actually see what this and i watched it
and i was like wait this is everything
everyone always says in pop culture they
reference all of these lines that all
made sense for me and it clicked now
every time it's on i watch it
love that we want that check you know
what i mean you got to kill its
residuals up we got to get it we got to
get it real housewives of dubai
lindsay lohan
is that a thing i i it's breaking here
first because i've never heard of this
no it's a dream of mine oh my gosh
okay it's just a dream
okay i have a petition and i wanted to
know if you'd sign it the thing i don't
think we can get lindsay to do a real
housewives show because she's so much
bigger than any housewife in the world
here he is a legend and she is her own
country like it'd be like more of like
you want to go to lindsay's country and
just live with her
so the real housewives of lindsay lohan
yes that's right yes but she's she's got
her i'm so proud of lindsay she has her
netflix deal she has that movie that
just came out like there's she has a
christmas movie coming out like so many
things she has an amazing podcast you
can listen to the low hand down isn't it
the lowdown or something
right it's so good so i'm just so proud
of her she's doing so well and just
crushing it i love that and then you
guys have a podcast is it going to be
this vibe that i'm feeling this but it's
yes
okay so here's what happened i heart
called us up and said hey do you want to
do a podcast i said we don't know what
we would talk about and they said it's a
gay podcast i'm like well we're real
good at being gay so let's do a podcast
about it so we are doing pridecast on
iheartradio it is so much fun it's a
celebration of the lgbtq plus community
where we come together celebrate what
all the awesome things that people are
doing in the community and lift
everybody up i love that well i feel
lifted and i guess you're not signing my
petition for lindsay lohan but that's
fine no no lindsay it's fine you just
keep doing you we'll keep doing
broadcast and we'll see you on the show
i just want to see that dance that she
did in dubai
yep get it get it get it get it as a
person that has come in 12th place on
dancing with the stars i can tell you
that
that is if you want me if you want the
person that's going to get voted off
first of the reality show sign me up
that's i'm the one to go to well check
thank you so much it was a pleasure you
guys are so fun very gemini very gemini
uh-huh
[Music]